democratic nominee joe biden visited
kenosha wisconsin yesterday
two days after the president it was
biden's first trip as a candidate to
that battleground state
he met with community members and the
family of jacob blake the black man shot
seven
times in the back by a white police
officer
biden's message was very different than
the president's
as ed o'keefe reports
just off the plane in wisconsin joe
biden met with jacob blake's family
blake's now out of the icu and phoned
into the meeting from his hospital bed
biden later described their conversation
he talked about how
nothing was going to defeat him
how whether he walked again or not he
was not going to give up
the visit was a far different scene from
the presidents earlier in the week
which focused on law and order we've
seen tremendous violence
and we will put it out very very quickly
if given the chance
the former vice president spoke during a
meeting at a church with kenosha
residents
there is a pain in my section of town
mr mr blake was shot two hou
two blocks from my house it's way more
that we want done
and it didn't just start with jacob
biden addressed racism
i thought you could defeat hate
hate only hides and talked about changes
he would try to make
if he's elected there will be a national
commission on policing
out of the white house where i'll bring
everyone to the table including police
chiefs including civil rights activists
including the naacp
including the african the
latino community kenosha is still
reeling from blake's shooting and the
aftermath
diner owner julie rittmiller said she
wants her city to heal
it's just heartbreaking i mean i
understand the anger
i'm hoping that this brings everybody
together
biden is set to speak later this morning
here in his hometown of wilmington
delaware about the economy and he's set
to keep a more aggressive travel
schedule
with stops scheduled next week in
michigan in pennsylvania
he's also weighed in on that atlantic
magazine article that ben told you about
a little while ago saying in a statement
that if the president's comments about
american service members
are true it would be quote another
marker of how deeply president trump and
i disagree
about the role of the president of the
united states
gail ed thank you very much